to be here in the hometown this is not
always the easiest place to travel to
for people so for the amount of all the
crew and everybody here that came to
make all this happen it was it's a
really big deal not just for me but all
the people in the town and it was a
really exciting time for them to have
these shows it's an honor for him to
come back you know you think he's really
busy I mean you know he's got he's got a
tour coming up and it's just great that
he made time to come down here and play
for us it speaks volumes for him and who
that he is and that he's so willing to
come back here and do a free concert
Chris was in my first homeroom mmm 26
years ago seventh seventh grade very
gifted very gifted even as a little boy
he was the valedictorian of the class of
96 he was also an athlete here and now
he is a two-time Grammy Award winning
artist mr. Chris Stapleton and give it
up
chris is a man of not so many words but
you can tell on his face and you can
tell on Morgan's face how much this
means to them to come home and and see
everyone and meet the people that really
made Chris the person he is today it's
pretty special I come from a family of a
lot of hard workers my dad was a coal
miner and he would get up at 4:30 in the
morning and he'd come home about 8
o'clock at night my grandfather was the
same way he had a 10th grade education
and wound up had a mention earring for a
multinational corporation he was a hard
worker and I learned that from those
guys and you know I don't know any other
way Chris Stapleton story of
perseverance and hard work and
dedication to take him from a community
like Paintsville and bring him to you
know winning Grammys and winning Academy
Country Music Awards is something that
we're very proud to be a part of
the roads been long I don't know how
hard it's been I've always had fun I've
done it for a living for a long time and
in different ways as a songwriter and
I've never looked at it as hard maybe
the hours belong sometimes but you know
I've always you know been grateful just
to get to play music for a living
you